من عاصمه الانوار الى مكب للنفايات باريس
تغرق في اطنان من القمامه هذه الايام فما
الذي يحصل في العاصمه الفرنسيه ولماذا
سيصبح الوضع خطيرا ان استمر اطنان القمامه
المتكبسه في شوارع باريس تاتي نتيجه
لاضراب عمال النظافه المتواصل منذ اسابيع
على قانون رفع سن التقاعد 62 الى 64 عاما
لكن خطرا انتشار القمامه يولد خطرا اكبر
بسبب الجلفان فالعاصمه الفرنسيه تعد من
اكثر المدن اكتظاظا بالجرذان في البلاد
فعادتها ضعف عدد سكانها فمقابل اكثر من
مليون باريسي هنالك نحو سته ملايين جرد
فالوضع في المدينه حاليا بث مناسبا لهذه
الحيوانات لتنتشر بشكل اكبر واكبر الامر
الذي اثار القلق من كارثه صحيه مرتقبه
لقطره هذه الق ليس فقط على تشويه سمعه
اكثر الوجهات السياحيه رقيا لكن ايضا على
نقل امراض خطيره معديه
مثل سلمونيلا وديدان وفارسات الهانزا وان
سلمى سكان باريس من شر جربان لن يفلتوا من
تاثير تحلل النفايات المتكدسه في الشوارع
التي ستتحول الى غازات سامه كالكبريت
وثاني اكسيد الكربون ما يؤثر على جهاز
التنفسي اضافه الى انها بيئه مناسبه
لانتشار البكتيريا السامه التي يمكن ان
تنتقل الى الانسان عن طريق اللمس او
التسرب الى مياه الشرب والمياه الجوفيه
التي تستهلك بشكل مباشر من